Ah beh, t'es là!
C'est Kurt!
Salut.
Bon, on a cru que tu viendrais pas.
Ouais, j'ai failli rester chez moi parce que j'avais vraiment pas le moral...
Argh... Allez, viens, tu vas voir, on fait un jeu, c'est marrant.
Attends, j'en ai un marrant pour Kurt.
Hop.
Et tiens, ça c'est pour toi.
Allez, c'est moi qui commence.
Hum... Je tue des gens avec un arc?
Ouais.
Beh c'est moi?
Non... Non pas du tout. A toi.
J'ai vraiment pas le moral les gars...
- Non.
Je suis vraiment au bout de rouleau.
- Ah beh non, pas du tout, non.
En fait, j'aimerais bien mourir.
- Mais non!
Bon allez à moi... Je cours dans la forêt mais je ne transpire presque pas?
Ouais.
Beh c'est moi alors...
Mais non, ce n'est toujours pas ça! Bon, à moi.
Est-ce que je suis un homme?
- Ouais!
Ok. J'ai une famille?
- Ouais...
Est-ce que je me sacrifie pour eux jusqu'à faire des trucs illégaux?
Non pas vraiment, je crois pas.
J'ai un don caché?
Ouais, tu gères aux patins à roulettes.
Candéloro.
- (rire) Non pas du tout.
(cri Chewbacca)
- Ok à toi Chewi.
- Non.
(cri Chewbacca)
- Toujours pas non.
- Non !
(cri Chewbacca)
- Non !!
- Non.
(cri Chewbacca)
- Non !!!!!
Bon, on passe à quelqu'un d'autre?
- Ouais, à moi!
Ok...
Euh, est-ce que je suis un homme?
Techniquement oui, mais humainement, tu es vraiment une merde.
Ah! Ok. Hum, non mais si je suis...
- Non, t'es une grosse merde. T'es un genre de tas de merde.
D'accord, je suis un dictateur?
- Oui voilà, t'es un dictateur et on voudrait tous que tu crèves la gueule ouverte! Tu comprends ça?
Je suis un nazi?
- Non mais tu vaux pas mieux, t'es qu'une pourriture!
Bon, maintenant à moi!
Je fais des cascades avec des vêtements ultra sexy qui font de moi une espèce de sex symbol?
Oui.
- Ah beh c'est moi alors, c'est sûr!
Non.
- Lara Croft, c'est moi!
Non, c'est pas toi, on a dit que c'était pas toi! Pff
- Ce n'est pas marrant d'avoir mis mon propre prénom, franchement, c'est pas drôle.
Non... Bon arrête... Ça fait trois fois que je te dis que c'est pas toi. A vous, professeur!
Yannick, le troisième mec dans l'orchestre sur le pont supérieur dans Titanic, celui qui joue de la trompette avec les belles moustaches.
- Pff...
Hum, ok...
Guernica!
Putain!
-Non...
Sinon, on peut faire un pendu?